[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Once we have
our APIs enabled,
head to the IoT Core page
to create a device registry.
Give it a name, and choose
your closest region,
then use MQTT protocol.
Under Default Telemetry
Topic, create a new topic.
Give that a name, then
click Create to create
your new device registry
with an associated Pub/Sub
topic for publishing
the telemetry events.
Now switch to your terminal
to generate a device key pair.
Back to the IoT Core
registry details page.
We will add a device.
Go to the Devices tab,
then click Create a Device.
Enter a device ID, and
then choose RS256_X509 5
under the Public Key Format.
Get the text from the
rsa_cert.pem file that you
generated earlier, including
the BEGIN CERTIFICATE and END
CERTIFICATE lines, and paste
it into the Public Key Value
field.
Click Create to add this
device to the registry.
Now, you'll run some code
and connect to this device
and view the telemetry data.
Grab this node code from
GitHub for IoT Core.
Navigate to the
mqtt_example folder.
Copy the private key from
before to this folder.
Then install the
node dependencies.
Now you can create a
subscription to the Pub/Sub
topic that this registry uses.
Next, connect to the virtual
device with the Cloud IoT Core
over the MQTT bridge.
If everything is
set up correctly,
you'll now see 25 payload
messages published.
Check the Pub/Sub
topic now to confirm
it's getting messages
published to it.
You can run that Pub/Sub
subscriptions pull command
again to get more messages.
And congratulations.
You've got your Internet
of Things service running
on Google Cloud.